I worked with this crazy psychologist he
he used to put jokes on his
multiple-choice tests he was a really
eccentric guy but I really liked his
courses he and he taught a course on
creativity and he was also a prison
psychologist and he was an eccentric guy
and he for some reason like me and maybe
because I was eccentric too and he
invited me to go out to the Edmonton
maximum security prison with him a
couple of times which I did and that was
a very interesting experience because I
was trying to figure out what role each
individual's behavior bore to the
pathology of the group was something
like that and I went out there and I met
a little guy smaller than me I was a
little bigger by then and he was a
pretty innocuous guy and what had
happened was I was out in this gymnasium
it looks like a high school the prison
which is really quite telling in my
estimation but and there were all these
like monsters in there weightlifting and
like they were monsters I remember one
guy it was tattooed everywhere and he
had like a huge scar running down the
middle of his chest it looked like
someone had to hit him with an axe and
you know and and I was in there and I
had this weird cape that I used to wear
that I bought in Portugal and some boots
that went along with it and yeah I was
like an 1890s Sherlock Holmes cape and
it was really like it was from the 1890s
because this little village was up on a
hill it was a walled city on a hill and
they sold these things and I don't think
they'd changed the style since 1890 and
so I thought they were really cool and
so I was wearing that which wasn't
perhaps the most conservative garb to
dawn if you're going to wear if you're
going to go to a maximum-security prison
so anyways I was in the gymnasium and
the psych are the psychologists left and
god only knows I mean that's what he was
like and all these guys came or all
these guys came around me you know and
they were offering to trade their prison
clothes for my cape and it was it was
like I was being made an offer I
couldn't refuse you know and so I didn't
I didn't really know what to do and then
this little guy said something like that
the psychologist sent me to come and
take you away or
something like that and so I thought
well better this little guy than all
these monsters so we went outside the
gym through some doors like school doors
we went outside the gym into the
exercise yard I guess and we were
wandering along and he was talking to me
and he seemed like it kind of an
innocuous guy and then the psychologist
showed up at the door and motioned us
back and so which was kind of a relief
and so I went into his office and he
said you know that guy that you walked
out in the yard with and I said yeah he
said he he took two cops one night and
he had them kneel down and while they
were begging for their lives he shot
them both in the back of the head and I
thought hmm that's see the thing that
was so interesting was that he was so
innocuous right because what you'd hope
is that someone like that would be very
much unlike you let's say and certainly
wouldn't be like someone innocuous that
you'd met what you'd want is that the
guy would be like you know half were
wolf and half vampire so you could just
tell right away that he was a
cold-blooded killer but no he was this
sort of ineffectual little guy who was
certainly not ineffectual if you gave
him a revolver in the upper hand and so
so that made me think that made me think
a lot about the relationship between
being innocuous and and being dangerous
and then another thing happened I met
another guy out there and then a week or
two later I heard that he and a friend
of his had held another guy down and
pulverized his left leg with a lead pipe
like just pulverized it and the reason
for that was that they thought that he
was a snitch and maybe he was and at
that time I did something different
instead of being shocked and horrified
by that although I certainly was I
thought how in the world could you do
that because I didn't think I could do
that I didn't think that I thought that
there was a qualitative distinction
between me and those people and so I
spent about two weeks trying to see if I
could figure out under what conditions I
could do that like what kind of
psychological transformation I would
have to undergo to be able to do that
and so that was a meditative exercise
let's say and it only took about ten
days
for me to realize that not only could I
do that that it would be a hell of a lot
easier than I thought it would be and
that's sort of where that wall between
me and what Jung described as the shadow
started to fall apart and that also was
very useful because I started to wreck I
started to treat myself as somewhat
different entity because I hadn't been
aware up to that point you know cuz I
thought I was a good guy and there's no
reason for me to think that because
you're not a good guy unless you've
really made a bloody effort to be a good
guy
you're just not it's not easy and so
you're probably a moderately bad guy and
that's a long ways from being an
absolutely horrible guy but it's also a
long ways from being a good guy and so
but I had a little more respect for
myself after that because I also
understood that there was a monstrous
element to the human psyche that that
you needed to respect and that was part
of you that you should regard yourself
in some sense as a loaded weapon it's
very useful around children to regard
yourself as a loaded weapon because
around children you are a loaded weapon
and the terrible experiences that many
children have with their parents are
testament to that